So in this lesson we've discussed some very important ideas about motivation
and emotion. So in motivation we've seen how needs states lead to drive and
then those drives lead to motivated behaviors. We've also discussed how these
could be arranged in hierarchy from the most basic, like physiological and
safety needs. All the way up to higher level needs of self-esteem and
self-actuaization. We've also talked about incentives, and how incentives are
important rewards for doing things well. We've talked about two basic needs.
Sex, and hunger. And sex is about survival of the species, hunger is about
survival of the individual. And with sex we've seen, for instance, the brain
system that regulates it is the hypothalamus. And the hormones involved in
regulating sexual behavior are mostly testosterone. Likewise, with hunger we've
seen how the brain, again the hypothalamus, regulates hunger as well as the
blood, glucose levels and then finally, again, hormones. But this time, leptin,
ghrelin, and insulin, for example. And then we've also seen how culture very
much shapes what we eat. And we call that cuisine. So we've also talked about
emotion. And emotions are experienced when we think of something as both
meaningful and harmful or beneficial to our well being. In another words, how
we praise events shape the emotions we experience. So for instance, if we think
something has been lost we might experience the emotion of sadness. If we think
something is a threat to us, we might experience the emotion of either fear or
anger. Emotions are accompanied by changes in our physiology, in our
expression. And in our feeling states. Now emotions and moods, are not the
same. Emotions are a result from specific events, and they tend to be very
short, in duration. Moods, on the other hand are often come about from
something very vague, and they're much more longer lasting. And then affective
traits are personality dispositions. So some people are more likely to
experience anger, and sadness, or anxiety, for instance. And then, lastly we've
talked about how the stereotypes of men and women being different in emotion
are not really all that true. A lot of the time, men and women in fact express
emotion very much the same way. We did see however, that women are better at
talking about emotion precisely and also reading emotion on people's faces and
in their voices.